are you ready for the next step in Call
of Duty multiplayer Activision has
finally given us a look I'm Tony this is
a game spot news update and this is
infinite Warfare's multiplayer the
biggest change is the addition of rigs
each of these loadouts supports
different play styles and they come
equipped with unique perks called traits
and gadgets called payloads you can
choose one trait and one payload when
you start a game allowing you to mix and
match the way you play against others
traits include stat boosts like extended
sliding and accelerated healing payloads
include crazy weapons like riot shields
and vaporizing handguns altogether the
combination of rigs traits and payloads
makes the game adapt to your exact play
style whether you prefer to rush the
objective or hang back and support
others like previous Call of Duty games
infinite warfare is getting a
multiplayer beta it'll launch first for
ps4 on October 15th with other platforms
coming at a later date you can tune into
GameSpot for plenty of beta footage when
things kick off and for all the biggest
call of duty news you're already in the
right place
you
you